the rise of social media as the primary
form of social interaction changed the
way that we judge people we once used to
judge people mostly based on their deed
but in the age of social media we judge
people mostly based on their words and
opinions because that's really all that
we see of them since we're defined by
our opinions there is pressure to have
an opinion on everything problem is
people generally don't have the time or
the will to research everything they are
expected to have an opinion on so they
copy the opinions of others and this
results in very few precious original
thinkers in this way the culture war is
largely two armies of NPCs being
ventriloquized by a handful of actual
thinkers and that is from the Fantastic
gwendebogle it is very very true if you
think about what most people's opinions
are they are a carbon copy poor rough
hewn version a counterfeit of whatever
the people that they look up to believe
and you know this is true for almost
everybody it's very hard to come up with
a fresh idea